- Mélanie et Jean-Martin
se questionnent.
- Bonjour, vous allez bien?
- Oui, ça va bien, toi?
- Oui, super. Ça va bien, merci.
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour vous aujourd'hui?
- On a pas mal de questions.
- Devraient-ils attendre ou
s'acheter un véhicule électrique
maintenant? Aujourd'hui,
ils viennent voir le modèle XC40
chez Volvo, à Ville Mont-Royal.
Propriétaire d'une résidence en
Gaspésie, le couple s'inquiète
de l'autonomie de la batterie
en hiver.
- Est-ce qu'il va falloir
que je rajoute cinq heures
dans mon trajet pour faire
deux ou trois arrêts?
RÉMI FORTIN-MURRAY,
Volvo Cars Mont-Royal
- Ça va vraiment dépendre
du kilométrage exact, de ce que
vous allez faire comme
accélération, aussi de la
vitesse que vous allez rouler.
Il y a beaucoup de vecteurs
qui vont changer le tout.
Mais moi, je calculerais...
Neuf heures de route, moi,
je calculerais vraiment au moins
1 h 30, 2 h de plus.
- De longs trajets possibles,
grâce à un réseau de bornes
de recharges plus étoffé.
Il y en a plus de 7000 à travers
le Québec, dont 800 bornes
rapides, ce qui élimine
l'angoisse de la panne.
Reste la question de l'usure
de la batterie, qui préoccupe
aussi Mélanie et Jean-Martin.
- On peut s'attendre à quoi,
dans le fond, dans 4 ans,
par exemple?
- On sait pas vraiment à quoi
s'attendre. Ce que je peux vous
dire, je peux prendre l'exemple
des hybrides branchables qu'on
a, on a encore une très bonne
autonomie après quatre ans.
- Et si la composition des
batteries soulève des questions,
bien des experts le disent :
leur technologie s'est beaucoup
améliorée ces dernières années
et ça continue.
Et autre avantage,
selon Simon-Pierre Rioux,
les batteries peuvent avoir
plusieurs vies.
SIMON-PIERRE RIOUX, Association
véhicules électriques du Québec
- Alors qu'avec la batterie,
lorsqu'elle est en fin de vie,
parce que c'est un gros
réservoir énergétique,
on va être capable de recycler
de façon pratiquement indéfinie,
avec un 5 % de perte d'une fois
à l'autre, pour pouvoir créer
de nouvelles batteries.
- Si la voiture électrique reste
plus écologique que la voiture
à essence, certains considèrent
quand même que ce n'est pas
l'option la plus écologique.
- C'est l'objet même
qui est le problème.
- Selon Olivier Ducharme,
si on veut vraiment protéger
l'environnement, il faut surtout
moins d'autos sur nos routes,
alors que la tendance actuelle
est à la hausse; 2 % de plus
l'année dernière au Québec.
OLIVIER DUCHARME, auteur
"Ville contre automobiles"
- On va encore continuer de
vouloir avoir de plus en plus de
voitures et gaspiller de plus en
plus de ressources naturelles.
- Pour le couple, une voiture
électrique reste tout de même
un pas dans la bonne direction.
Si le prix d'achat élevé reste
un obstacle, les incitatifs
gouvernementaux, 8000 $
de Québec et 5000 $ du fédéral,
compensent en partie, sans
compter les économies d'essence
et d'entretien estimées
à 2000 $ au bout de 4 ans.
- On a pris la décision,
en fait, de se procurer un
véhicule électrique. C'est là
que tout le monde est rendu.
Je me sens de mon temps.
- Ils ne sont pas seuls.
Il se vend en moyenne,
au Québec, 135 véhicules
électriques chaque jour.
Pour rouler vert, il faut
toutefois s'armer de patience.
Le temps d'attente,
selon le fabricant, varie
de deux semaines à plus d'un an.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa